Unknown: All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone. It is
an honor to host the enema. And
undo Kumar, who is a professor
at Caltech and director of ml
research at Nvidia. She was
previously a Principal Scientist
at Amazon Web Services. And uma
is really a pine pine pine
pioneer pioneer of the neural
operators. And today she is
willing to talk about ml for
solving PDS neural operators on
the function spaces. Yeah, so
any maths yeah, thanks for all
yours.
Thank you, Yong Soo, and great
to be here. Sorry for the delay,
you know, the WebEx I haven't
used in a long time. So some
teething problems, but yeah, so
I'm happy to talk about neural
operators, and what is the
methodology behind it? Why that
is suitable for different
scientific applications,
including solving partial
differential equations? And also
why not just the standard neural
network tools, right, what is
special about neural operators?
Yeah, so indeed, you know, if
you want to think about modeling
multiscale processes in a
variety of scientific domains,
you know, this is very
challenging, right? I mean, the
scales are enormous, you can go
all the way down to problems at
the quantum level, looking at
interactions as wave functions
between electrons in a molecule
and using that to predict the
properties, especially when it
comes to designing new drugs or
materials. This is important,
all the way to the planetary
scale, if you want to predict
the weather or climate, how we
can look at microscopic
interactions and the impact it
has globally at planetary
scales. And that's the aspect
that is so challenging tomorrow.
And of course, there's so many
other problems in between as
well, that are multiscale in
nature. And this is different
from text or image processing,
right, that we've seen a lot of
exciting developments. But that
doesn't directly translate into
our ability to model these
processes. Text is discrete
data. Again, image processing.
Typically, you'll just think of
doing that at one fixed
resolution. Right, and it's
object centric and natural
images, you are main goal is to
reduce from this pixel space to
some low dimensional
representation that is centered
around objects, you know, for
instance, segmenting the objects
being able to recognize the
objects. So that's where a lot
of the focus is on, right, going
from these pixel dimensions to
low dimensional space. On the
other hand, if you think about
these multi scale processes,
there's information in all
scales, right. So you cannot
quick, easily read use it to
some high level representation,
like we do with image
processing. And so we need to
think of different frameworks to
be able to nicely capture all of
the scales and do high fidelity
modeling. And as an example, I
want to show the challenges in
modeling climate, are the one
big source of uncertainty. In
fact, the biggest source of
uncertainty is the presence of
these low lying clouds, what we
call stratocumulus. Clouds, and
the turbulence in them. So the
ability to model the turbulence
at very fine spatial and
temporal scales is important. In
order to get very, you know, the
right answers, or the in these
micro scales, ultimately impact
the macro behavior. And what my
colleague tapeo Schneider
estimates is, you really need to
go down to one meter spatial
resolution, planet wide. And
that requires about 100 billion
times more computing than what
we have today. And so if you're
trying to do standard numerical
methods, and we need to go to
these fine scales, it's just
very out of reach to be able to
do that, right in a brute force
manner. And so right now, our
capabilities are barely getting
to one kilometer, right. So
that's also not fully there, we
are still getting to that
resolution. And so there's a big
gap between what we can do
today, versus what we really
need to do to capture the fine
scales and climate modeling. And
so that's just one of the
examples. The same is true with
quantum chemistry or multitude
of other examples I showed you,
we cannot get to the level of
computation needed to capture
all the scales of the problem.
And also, you know, in this
case, we are going from bottom
up physics, right, so we are
starting with partial
differential equations, each
time, we are redoing all of the
computations to get us to the
answers. So the question is,
what is the role of data driven
methods that could learn from
previous data, and be able to do
these computations much faster.
So, this is where I think
machine learning can have a very
big impact, you know, helping us
build on top of accelerated
computing, you know, GPUs are
indeed the workhorse of AI. So
getting all those hardware,
accelerations and efficiency,
and of course, supercomputing
scale. So we'll use all of that.
But machine learning is really
the enabler of that scale,
right? It's going to help us
leapfrog and get us very big
speed ups, in terms of being
able to do much faster
computations. If we can avoid
the fine grid required for
numerical methods and get away
with coarser grits, we get away
with not having to do
intermediate iterations and get
to the answers faster. Because
we learn the features that are
relevant to that domain, then we
can really leapfrog in our
computational abilities. And I
think that's the promise. And we
will also see in many
applications, we are able to get
very impressive speed ups. And
we're able to maintain the
fidelity or sometimes even
surpass it compared to
traditional methods. Yeah, so
let me first start with a
framework and give an overview
of what neural operator is,
right. So what makes it
different from standard neural
networks, I think I told you
just a few slides ago that we
cannot use the same models as
text or image processing,
because we need to capture all
of the scales. And I think
that's the key difference. If we
used any of the standard neural
networks for image processing,
whether it's convolutional
neural network, or vision
transformers, they're typically
trained to work at a fixed
resolution. So you have training
data at one resolution, and you
also have testing data at the
same resolution. On the other
hand, if we are thinking about
solving scientific problems, as
I mentioned, we need to capture
many different scales. And not
only that, we need to be able to
query at any scale, right? So if
you use any of the scientific
methods, any numerical methods,
we have the flexibility of
having different grids, right?
So in fact, different problems
and tell different shapes of
grids. For instance, the
airfoil, you know, typically we
have this non uniform grid,
because you want more finer grid
near these sharp points. And so
this flexibility to go different
shapes of grids, as well as
query at any point, because the
phenomenon is no continuous
domain is important. And so
standard neural networks don't
have that capability. And so the
question is, how do we design
neural operators that can mimic
the capabilities of current
numerical methods, but are also
having high fidelity are
expressive, they're able to
capture the multiscale
phenomena. And they're fast,
right? So we need to be able to
do all of this at once. So
that's where our inspiration
comes from, the ability to solve
first linear partial
differential equations. So as a
thought process, if we start
with asking what is an efficient
way to learn solutions for
linear partial differential
equations, you can think of this
form of the solution right the
inverse of differential
operators the integral operator,
and we can look towards building
a block here that learns to
solve this integral linear
operator. So, this is now a
building block that can solve
linear partial differential
equations. For instance, the
heat diffusion equation is
linear partial differential
equation. And in some cases, we
even know this kernel or this
greens function and
analytically. In other cases,
you have to numerically compute
it. But the key is here solving
linear partial differential
equations involves, you know,
learning the kernel or this
greens function and also being
able to integrate that on the
continuous domain. So because
this integration is over the
continuous domain, you can now
give your input at any different
discretization, right, and you
would still be able to have the
output be at any discretization.
So that's the key difference
from a standard neural network
where the input is only in a
fixed discretization of fixed
grid. Here, we have the
flexibility to have the input in
any point in the continuous
domain, because it's computing
this integration at any point.
And so that's the key aspect
that is,
you know, will be different from
standard neural networks. And
also now the question is how do
we compute this efficiently
right. So there is two aspects.
One is how do we compute this
efficiently? The other aspect
is, how do I extend this beyond
linear equations to nonlinear
equations, you know, so many
phenomena of interest that I
showed you, fluid dynamics for
climate modeling, or quantum
chemistry, right. So, you know,
many of the especially
approximations of that become
nonlinear problems. So we need
to be able to handle non
linearity. And so that's where
we introduce a more general
framework that takes these
blocks that learn integral
linear operators, and compose
that with non linearity. So
these compositions of integral
linear operators with nonlinear
activations, you know, they can
be standard, nonlinear
activations, like ReLU, or Gelu.
Usually Gallo, because we want
also second order derivatives,
right. In many of these
differential equations, they
involve second order
derivatives. So we want that
smoothness. And so we use a
function like Gallo, for a
nonlinear activation. But that's
a detail, but the general
framework is that by composing
linear blocks with nonlinear
activations, we get an
expressive model. And this is
the same philosophy as a
standard neural network, because
even there, you have a linear
function and you compose with
nonlinear activation. The linear
function in fully connected
neural network is matrix
multiplication in convolutional
neural network is convolution.
Right, by the same philosophy
holds here that we compute a
linear operator, and then we
compose with non linearity. The
only difference is this is now
learning a linear operator, as
opposed to a linear function. So
this operator maps a continuous
input to an input in a
continuous domain to an output,
which is also a function on
continuous domain. Right? So
that's the main difference.
Panama, muddy has a question
about are the inputs here
location time and outputs the
solution of the equations?
So the input can be both space
and time, right? So to be input
is any function on a continuous
domain? And that domain could be
space or time or both, or
anything else as well. So this
general framework as you know,
that's that's one option. Okay,
thank you. Great. And again,
yeah, if there are further
questions here, do feel free to
interrupt me. So that's the
framework. Now, of course, one
thing I haven't told you is how
to learn these integral linear
operators efficiently. And so
one framework that has been very
successful is what we call for
your neural operator where we
relaxed the kernel to a
convolutional kernel. So meaning
you only look at translations,
right. And this is, indeed a
limitation compared to the
general kernel. But because we
compose it with nonlinear
activations, we can show that
it's still expressive and in
fact, you know, both this
original neural operator as well
as the convolution based neural
operator are both universal
approximator errs. So you can
approximate any nonlinear
operator, which is a mapping
from one function space to
another with these frameworks,
and I think In this is important
to be able to capture, as I
said, any nonlinear operator. So
but of course, this I have just
made this simplification. But
what is this bias? Right? Why is
this more efficient to learn a
convolutional operator. So this
is where we can do change of
basis, we can go from
convolution to element wise
multiplication in the Fourier
domain, for instance. So, we
know Fourier basis is a good
inductive bias for many
problems, including fluid
dynamics, it's been used for
numerical methods as well. So we
can use that inspiration and say
Fourier domain is a good
inductive bias. And not only
that, it becomes much more
efficient to learn the
coefficients in the Fourier
domain, right. So this way, the
integration over the continuous
domain just becomes matrix
multiplication. So, this is
efficient. And we can learn the
coefficients in an efficient
manner. So, that's the principle
it's very simple, that we can
transform our input into the
Fourier domain, we learn the
coefficients in the Fourier
domain, and we go back to the
standard domain. And then we do
non linearity in the standard
domain, which could be space and
time. And we then repeat this
again. So, a few points here,
right, so, first of all, you
know, if he did just this
convolutional operator in the
Fourier domain, without non
linearity, that would be
limiting, right. So, and in
fact, that's what the numerical
methods to they transform to the
Fourier domain, and they judge
to iteration there. On the other
hand, we have nonlinear
activation. So we have the now
flexibility to not just, you
know, it's not just limited to
the Fourier spectrum of the
original signal, we're also
learning features over nonlinear
activations. So that's a
benefit. The other benefit, we
can get us through
regularization, or we can
capture only the low frequency
modes in the first layer. So we
just filter out and only retain
low frequency modes here. Of
course, if you didn't have non
linearity, this would be a
strong aliasing, right. So this
will lead to errors. Because
many signals of interest have
high frequency components, so
you can't just threshold them.
But on the other hand, because
we have nonlinear activations
present, we can further
transform the signal and still
have the ability to capture high
frequency content. And that's
why we are able to provide the
guarantees of universal
approximation, even though in
each layer, we are using a
regularization to keep low
frequency modes. Of course,
that's a hyper parameter of how
much do you threshold to retain
low frequency modes? versus how
many layers do you have, right,
so both are hyper parameters, we
can choose for different
problems. But really, the
benefit is the ability to now
make learning efficient, as well
as key the discretization
invariance, meaning I can now
input my signal at any
resolution, or you know, with
any resolution, I can still
capture the signal through
Fourier transform, right,
because I can do Fourier
transform at any resolution. And
that's a key ingredient that
makes this overall framework end
to end discretization invariant.
By that what I mean is, let me
first show you just an example
of proof of concept in terms of
showing how we can, you know,
train in one resolution and test
in a different resolution,
right, which wouldn't be
possible with standard neural
networks. So we're training
using only coarse resolution
data for this Nabeel stokes
equation. And we do that over
different initial conditions,
and then a testing time we
provide higher resolution
inputs, and then we look at how
well does it predict right and
what we see is indeed that does
predict pretty well. And in can
see that in fact, in the
frequency spectrum as well that
the prediction is very graceful,
even beyond the scene
resolution, meaning it
extrapolates to higher
resolution without seeing it
during training. So this is what
we mean by zero short super
resolution. And you can see that
here that you know, there is
right I mean, these systems are
dissipative so you do have to
see the drop off of the energy
spectrum. But, you know, when we
are given training data at a
fixed resolution, we only see
these wave numbers, right. So
these we have no idea what the
higher wave numbers are. But in
cases where there is a nice drop
off, our framework is able to
track that compared to other
standard frameworks like unit. I
think there was another
question.
Yes, there was another question
by Ahmadi. He said, this also
assumes that the set of
equations that represents the
physics in one scale is also
valid in another scale, right?
Yeah, we are currently assuming
there's only a fixed set of
equations, right. So the way I
mean, I haven't even used the
equations, right. So if you're
using the equations in a physics
informed manner, that would
matter. In this case, we're just
giving data, right? There's no
physics knowledge built into the
model. But what really, you
know, where this will work well,
is when there's a nice drop off
in terms of energy, right? In
these higher frequencies. If
you, for instance, have
something very arbitrary like
this, right, some arbitrary
spectrum here, that is having
very high energy content, you
know, we cannot expect to
capture in because we have
absolutely no information about
that.
Alright, he also asked what is
what is the difference between
two scales, backed up by 200?
You can see that here, right?
The wave numbers. So these are
the wave numbers we provide, we
can go all the way up to 200. So
we provide a little more than
what it's 25 wave numbers of 30,
something like that. And, and we
can go much further. We can go
to any scale, right? The
prediction can happen at any
scale.
Sounds good. Thank you. aneema.
Yeah.
Yeah, so just to kind of make
this point about discretization
invariance, what can we
guarantee right, as I mentioned,
we cannot guarantee that we will
give you as error free answer at
any resolution, because that's
impossible. If we do not see
higher resolution inputs, you
know, there's no way we can
capture all of the information
about it. On the other hand,
what we can guarantee is
graceful degradation, right?
Graceful, like kind of having
consistent answers, even as we
refine the mesh. So the idea is
you keep refining the mesh and
asking, what is the value? At
any point here, you should
converge to a limit. And
ideally, that limit should be
closer to the ground truth
operator. Right? So so what
we're guaranteeing is this kind
of convergence. And this is
something you may not, you know,
otherwise see in other
frameworks. And so just to kind
of make that point clear, in a
standard neural networks do not
have this ability, because most
of them, you can't even query at
any resolution, right? So the
standard architectures expect
always the resolution to be
fixed. Whereas neural operators
remove that dependence. There's
of course, an intermediate step
where you could use
interpolation on top of standard
neural network. So you train
your neural network at a fixed
resolution, you're using
standard fixed interpolation,
whether it's by linear
interpolation or any such
framework you can use on top
where there is no learning for
interpolation. So, that
framework indeed allows you to
query anywhere in the domain,
but it does not guarantee
universal approximation, because
the neural network just learns
that of fixed scale right. So it
is not learning in the function
space, like we do with neural
operators, and that to me, is
the big benefit we obtain here.
Yeah, so just to reiterate, the
framework of neural operators is
taking, you know, ways to
compute these integral linear
operator and composing with non
linearity to give it both
expressivity, but by learning
blocks that compute integral
linear operators, we still keep
discretization invariance. And
so that kind of like, you know,
ability to have both aspects of
discretization invariance and
non linearity is crucial. So,
there's an extensive library, I
encourage you to go check it
out, you know, it's open source
also contribute to it would be
great to hear your thoughts,
where we do have implementations
of the Fourier neural operator
that I mentioned, but also there
are other approaches right in
order to be able to estimate
this for instance, through graph
based method because you can
learn through a graph neural
network and message passing,
what is the relationship between
nearby points, and then you can
turn it into an operator,
because once you learn the
kernel, you can approximate the
integration as summation. So
this works well, if the
phenomena is fairly local. So
it's much harder to do for
global dependence like in fluid
dynamics, because you would need
the neighborhood to be very
large and that is expensive. So,
I think there are frameworks
where the graph based methods
are effective, and then there
are other domains especially
with where we know the operator
is highly non local, where
Fourier based methods are
effective, because you know, we
can express these kinds of
global dependence efficiently
through Fourier transforms.
Yeah, so far, what I mentioned
was just computing on a, you
know, practical implementation
was computing on a uniform grid,
right, because Fourier
transform, the efficient
implementation is fast Fourier
transform that assumes uniform
grid. And if you tried to do
Fourier transform on non uniform
grids showed that our
algorithms, but those
implementations are not
efficient. And so we wanted to
keep the Fourier transform as
fast Fourier transform on
uniform grid, and the way we
decided to handle non uniform
input domains, right, the
physical space, for instance,
this airfoil wing, this is a
irregular geometry shape. And we
also want a grid to be irregular
to capture that non uniformity.
So this is our input domain. So
what we propose is to learn a
deformation from this to a
uniform grid in a latent space.
And we know from topology that
such deformation sexes, so if
you assume this is homeomorphic,
to Taurus, you can learn that
transformation, right. And if
not, they can also there, you
decompose the domain into
multiple parts and piece them
together, which is a detail from
topology. But the idea is this
is very general. So in general,
you should be able to learn the
transformations from a physical
space that is irregular to a
latent space that is regular.
And so what we do is we learn
such deformations point wise.
And this way, we can go to a
latent space, and do efficient
computations and come back to
the standard domain. And so you
can see that where we credit
deformation for plastic fortune
here, and again, we see the you
know, really impressive speed
ups about 100,000 times speed up
over standard numerical methods.
And you can see the geometry is
changing over time, and it's
able to maintain and do that
prediction. So this is another
example where we, you know, can
handle irregular shape, in the
sense that the fluid is now
flowing through a catheter with
all these triangular shapes,
right, so we propose triangular
shapes as a way to limit the
bacterial contamination. So
what's known as the bacteria
swim upstream to the fluid flow,
and if we can reduce the size of
bacteria, by trapping it in
these triangular places, then we
can reduce the contamination.
And so one benefit with these
methods is that we can do
inverse design very effectively.
So not just in was designed any
kind of inverse problems because
the train neural operators are
differentiable, right? So we can
directly get the gradients back.
And so what we did was to ask,
you know, how can I find the
optimal triangular shape to
minimize the bacterial
contamination. So here, the
contamination should be ideally
zero because we don't want the
bacteria going back into the
patient. And so we were able to
do that by doing gradient
descent, which is very fast and
effective. And that's how we,
you know, we're able to very
quickly proposal design and our
collaborators 3d printed it and
tested it in the lab. And this
is just a visualization of, you
know, how we can see many
particles are getting trapped in
these triangular groups. Yeah,
and so this is another here.
demonstration with airfoil. If
you want to optimize for lift
versus drag, right, we can
directly do gradient descent and
come up with Yes, and here we
are having the simulation of the
fluid dynamics around the
aircraft wing, right. So we are
only training for the forward
model. So in the forward model,
we have many different aircraft
wings, we are predicting how,
you know, what is the fluid
dynamics around that, and, and
then we can directly do the
inverse problems. So, the key
is, you don't need to know, what
is the optimal design when
you're doing the training of the
neural operator. And you can do
the inverse and come up with the
optimal design. So far, I did
not incorporate any of the
physics, I think there was a
question earlier asteroid. So,
you know, how does it capture
the different scales. So, in
terms of if you want to really
capture the fine scales, and we
need to do that with high
accuracy, we would need to know
the equations as well. And so
the idea is, if the data is only
at coarse resolution, I now have
the flexibility to express my
equations at a much finer
resolution. And so this way, we
can capture both data and the
equations. And we can get to
high fidelity results. And so we
can then do zero short super
resolution very well, even at
higher resolutions. And we can
also further fine tune our
model, because, you know, during
training, we have a variety of
initial conditions and
solutions. But at test time, we
have a single initial condition,
right? So we want to do well on
this, we can further fine tune
with the equation loss on this
specific instance. And that way,
we get to a better error.
And so we can also do better
transfer learning with physics
based losses, because we can,
you know, learn the operator
safe on one Reynolds number, if
you want to fine tune on a
different Reynolds number, there
is a distributional shift. But
having the equation laws allows
us to quickly figure out what
the distribution change, right,
what parameter change, and still
utilize the information that
was, you know, in the earlier
train model. And so this leads
to faster convergence. Yeah, so,
so far, what I told you was to
learn deterministic maps between
function spaces, right, what
about learning probability
distributions on function
spaces? And indeed, this
directly, you know, asks similar
questions, as we've seen with
generative AI, whether it's text
generation image generation,
right, so they're all learning
probability distributions? Can
we do the same? And indeed, for
scientific computing, that's
very important, right? So
inverse problems, if you want
the posterior of your inverse
problem, that's a probability
distribution naturally, right?
uncertainty quantification,
learning like chaotic dynamics.
So you want to ask what are the
different attractors and what is
the distribution. So all of this
are about problems that require
probability distribution. And of
course, if you're looking at
stochastic differential
equations, or other stochastic
processes, those are also, you
know, involved learning
probability on function spaces.
So what we've recently derived
is a diffusion model, but now on
function spaces. And so we're
doing that by extending what is
known as core function in
diffusion models in finite
dimensional spaces to now score
operator, right, so this
operator maps a function space
of, of one domain to another.
And in this case, what we want
to do is map instead of Gaussian
noise, a Gaussian random field
to the output distribution. And
so this is the key difference
here. With Gaussian random
field, you can now sample at any
resolution. So you're no longer
limited to sampling at the
resolution of the training data,
like we see in image generation
models. And that's how we can
now you know, do this training
at low resolution and generate
high resolution images and still
get a very good fidelity of what
we generate, right. So if you
now have a density of initial
conditions, you want to capture
that random distribution of
solutions for these given
initial conditions. In this
example, you can see that we can
do very well. So I wanted to see
if there are further questions
before I I maybe showcase one or
two examples of using these
various methods.
Yeah. Marty, do you want to
unmute yourself? I see you
please raise your hand. Buddy,
are you there?
I don't, I don't hear. Okay.
See. Any other questions from
audience? anymore? You can move
on?
I think there's, I think there's
another question.
No, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I don't
think so you can move on. Okay.
Yeah, so to give you some
examples in OB train, using
these four year neural operator
and its variants on weather
data, so but this is era five
reanalysis data that's available
since the 1970s. So having this
wealth of historical weather
data, allows us to train a model
that's very accurate, as well as
fast. So here's a visualization
of the atmospheric rivers. And
you can see that it can capture
these very wide, you know that
those are 1000s of miles wide
phenomena that has a huge impact
on whether there are storms or
drought in the western coast
here. And not only that, it's
very fast, it's about 45,000
times faster than current
numerical weather models. So you
can also see that with
trajectory prediction, we can
predict these wind conditions,
and the high wind conditions are
in purple. And you can see our
prediction closely follows the
trajectory of Hurricane Matthew,
which was certainly not in the
training data, right. So we are
looking at how well it does on
new hurricanes. And it's able to
give you a good uncertainty
bound around the trajectory of
the hurricane. So these are some
more details. And we also have
some of our models open source
there, I welcome you to go check
it out. And what you can see is
the ability to have big speed
ups over current numerical
weather models, and at the same
time, good accuracy. So What
would take hours on a CPU
cluster for current numerical
weather models takes less than a
second on a single desktop GPU.
Yeah, and we continue to improve
this. I think we just recently
talked, I think, yesterday, the
talk was at Eichler workshop on
climate AI, where by
incorporating the spherical
geometry, so instead of the
Fourier, Fast Fourier Transform
on Euclidean space, we now have
spherical harmonics, and we
build that into our model. And
that leads to even better
extrapolation. So you can do
much longer rollouts than what
we had trained for. We trained
it just for a few time steps of
six hours or so. Right. So we
have very short range training.
But we can extrapolate the model
to long rollouts, and there's
good stability. And we continue
to improve the forecasting
skills as well compared to the
ifs, which is the current
numerical weather models. So
we've also used in a number of
other scenarios, to mitigate
climate change, carbon capture,
and storage is a big aspect. So
how do we model the buildup of
pressure as carbon dioxide is
pumped into these wells. So we
are now able to do multi well
modeling. So being able to look
at multiple wells at once. And
if you have a permeability map,
so you know how permeable the
ground is. And we can then use
that as the input. Given a
permeability map, we have high
resolution, a fine grid
prediction within the wells as
well as a coarser grid to
connect the different wells. And
you can see that we can model
the gas plume evolution as well
as the pressure buildup. And we
can do that over 30 year range.
And we can even do further if
needed. But the key is, you can
see that it has a very big speed
up about 700,000 times faster
than current numerical weather
models. So this are applicable
in many other scenarios as well.
You know, predicting air
turbulence for drone flights or
other flights is important. So
we've been testing it in the lab
by looking at turbulent
conditions here and using laser
laser measurements and showing
that we can do very nice real
time, fluid prediction directly
from noisy as experimental data,
and so we continue to test
models like this also in the
right physical hardware on the
lab to see how well we can
stabilize the airfoil wing and
many other cases. So just to
show like at Caltech, we also
have the finery where we can
test this very carefully on
different kinds of wind
conditions. So I think I already
mentioned the catheter before.
So let me Yeah, so, you know,
again, sorry for the delay, but
I hope you got a good overview
of what neural operators are,
what is the principle behind
designing them, and how they
differ from standard neural
networks and their ability to
capture multiple scales and do
inferences in a discretization
invariant manner. Thank you.
Sounds good. Thank you so much
for the wonderful talk. Anima. I
guess, did I miss the the
question from the Joseph, let's
have a q&a sessions. By the way.
Jews have asked, Are there any
special considerations for using
neural operator operators on
inverse problems.
Um, so there are different
options, right, so you can do
the, you can learn the neural
operator for the forward
problem, and then just take
gradients differentiate through
the model, or you can directly
learn the inverse mapping. And
so there are both options, or
you can couple both of them as
well. And also, in both of these
cases, you can ask, you know,
how do I also incorporate the
physics, right, so you can also
do the physics informed version.
And then there is the aspect
that to capture the not just
point estimates, but to get the
right proper posterior
distribution. You know, can we
use diffusion models? So what I
proposed efficient models and
function spaces.
Thank you. Okay. Another
question by Hawaii. For the CCS
case, the heavier team, try to
explore the super resolution
property of app No.
Yeah, we can certainly give
predictions, but we don't have
the ground truth. Right. So we
are now working with some
partners getting real data and
validating on that.
Awesome. Okay, next question is
by Faisal, what do you need to
train the neural operator? Do
you need the original PDE? Can
you learn on noisy ground
through?
Yeah, so we don't need the
original PDE. Right. So the
framework I described is very
general, the input can be any
function on a domain, and the
output is a function, right? So
you're learning that mapping.
And so you can take some data
from solvers, existing solvers,
like I showed you the Navier
stokes example. Or you can take
the weather example where the
data is already there, the
historical weather data and the
reanalysis data and we train on
it. So it can be very general.
Sounds good, okay. The equations
are there, we can incorporate
that as the loss function, in
addition to data
as you go in Pino, right. Okay,
the next question is by Rudy
Pang. And he asked for the
function mapping to learn from
PDE coefficient to solution, any
ideas what function spaces it is
in? And is the mapping unique?
So for
to learn from the coefficients
to the solutions? You know, the
PDE is well posed, you assume
there's a unique solution,
right. But we don't need to even
assume that as long as we have
the data that learns the
mapping, we can do that. But of
course, if it's unique, then you
have a good error. And you can
learn this well.
All right. Sounds good. So I
don't think there is any other
questions that have
raised their hands. Yeah, for
the for the FMO can see more
about like the boundary
conditions, especially like non
pure periodical boundary
conditions. And also for the
like the, in the carbon storage
case, you showed that to have
like, like the course grades,
for fields, and also like near
the well, like I have the high
high resolution grades. So how
you make the boundary conditions
consistency between these two?
Yeah, that's a good, that's a
great point. So for the first
generally, like for non periodic
cases, right, the four year
branch may not capture that very
easily. I mean, you can correct
that with four year continuation
methods. And we also propose
that but we also have
alternative branches, so we have
skipped connections. And so
that's a very efficient way to
capture non periodic conditions.
And so we've we have
architectures that I handle that
very efficiently. So in terms of
like, for the specific case of
CCS, what we did was a nested
fNo model. So we now have
different economic models for,
you know, within the well versus
outside, we have multiple
levels. And so they just share
the information across them.
That makes sounds good. Thanks.
Yeah. Have more questions? No.
Okay. So fNo is known to require
many, many data. And from your
experience, piano, if you
incorporate the physics, then do
you see that you require the
last data is required?
Absolutely. Our data requirement
goes down significantly? And of
course, it depends on the
hardness of the problem, right.
So, you know, some cases you may
even do with one data point,
that's the physic physics and
form neural network setting,
right? So if the optimization
landscape is very efficient, you
don't need any data at all, you
can directly solve for the
equation loss. And then there
are others that are high
dimensional, very hard, and you
may need more data. So there's a
whole spectrum of problems.
Okay. Sounds good. I have just
clarify qualification questions.
You said that people net is not
discretization independent, I
thought heroes discretize.
So this is there's a, so the
original deep on it that was
proposed was on assuming a fixed
input grid. So the input grid
was assumed to be fixed, the
output is also is still a
function. So the output is can
work at any resolution, but the
input was a fixed grid. And then
later on in the solution, others
proposed a solution as well to
fix that. But anyway, I wanted
the the original one had.
Yeah, I just wanted to clarify,
Chris. I think the current
version of the deponent Yeah,
that doesn't seem dependent.
Okay. Another question from CO
Juan Chang. What is the
regularity assumptions needed in
the function spaces? If the
solution is of low regularity?
For example, the domain is
singular and the function on its
roof, can the current framework
be applied?
Yeah. So we are working on like
kind of extensions of this in
terms of practical architecture.
But there's already theory
showing that you can use for
your neural operator to
approximate those well, as well,
like Sam Lanter and understood
have like a recent paper, but
yeah, this is something we're
working on.
Okay, yeah. I have
another question. For one. Yeah.
So for the transplant learning,
Eve, the differential equations
are different, like for
different problems, do you think
of that transfer learning is
still helpful or not? I know,
like in the same equations,
probably, it's like a helpful
forum. But But from the point of
view of different differential
equations.
Yeah, that's great. And that's
unclear, right? It's, again, the
same as any, you know, what we
see in other vision domains,
like how much is the shared
features, you might think some
of it is still shared? Because
numerical methods, right, like
kind of have similar approaches
for all these domains. So it may
still transfer. But it's a good
question. You know, how
effective it is? We haven't
tried it so far.
Yeah, we've sent comments on the
Ching chi, I mean, transfer
learning not on the neural
operator, but on the traditional
neural network, sensing a sense,
it hasn't been applied, you
know, the quiz or the different
PDE. And, you know, use that to
accelerator on the neural net
model on a PDE. That hasn't been
demonstrated, but I guess it's
an example by example.
Yeah, exactly. But it's I think,
I think I expect that there
should still be an advantage.
You're Osama
Osama useful, right. All right.
Any other questions from
audiences? Oh, yes, we do. Okay,
as the person from platano when
you compare the speed up to you
consider the training or data
generation time.
So, you know, no, I mean, these
numbers, we don't first of all,
it's still not a significant
amount, right. So because to me,
data is just something that you
know, you only do training once,
right, and then inference is
running cost. And so this is the
standard way of we would
evaluate Do any methods so,
because also there is cost that
goes into programming these
algorithms even for traditional
methods, so, so I would just you
know, to me that's something
that guy, you know, happens
before the solver comes online.
But we do report that in our
papers.
Got it? Another question by
muddy can the matter the
extrapolating new and unseen to
matrix?
Yeah, in the geometric fNo that
I proposed the ideas. That's how
you can see that even online
changing geometry of the
deformation, it's able to track
you should have some mapping
from, you know, once your metric
to another that
we just learned that we learn
that.
Okay, yeah.
All right. different geometries.
That's how we're able to
generalize it.
All right. Sounds good. Is there
any other questions from
audience? Now, let's thank our
speaker aneema for the wonderful
talk and, and good discussion
times, and
so on. Thanks, everyone. And
thanks for sticking around. I
really appreciate it. Yeah, and
I do reach out if you have
further questions.
That'd be awesome. Okay. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you,
everyone. We have another TDPs
seminar tomorrow. So see you
tomorrow. Bye now. Thank you.
Bye.